hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about metformin which is marketed
as glucophage okay this medication is
normally for diabetes type 2 and PCOS
polycystic ovarian syndrome and it
basically does two things it helps
increase sensitivity to insulin so it's
it improves insulin resistance as well
as the suppression of glucose production
from the liver okay because if your
livers making too much glucose it's
gonna raise the sugar so metformin will
chill that out and increase the
sensitivity so here's the hormone
insulin here's this receptor it comes in
it makes the connection and there's
resistance it allows the insulin to work
better in the cell okay well that sounds
great but two things one is the actual
root cause is rarely addressed like the
high levels of sugar in the diet are
rarely addressed the frequent eating is
rarely addressed if that was addressed
you could eventually improve it without
metformin so one of the challenges with
metformin is that it not only has side
effects diarrhea nausea abdominal pain
gas but it has a boxed warning which is
a very severe warning based on the FDA
that will spike lactic acid okay
which can then severely affect your pH
and create a lot of more serious
problems also it blocks the absorption
of b12 and folic acid so that has a
whole series of side effects connected
to that and in addition to that you
don't want to take metformin and if you
have a liver problem or a kidney problem
but who doesn't have a liver problem or
a kidney problem if they're pre-diabetic
in the first place
so it does come with a package so there
are some natural alternatives that you
can use in addition to metformin and by
the way check with your doctor before
taking this recommendation okay but you
can research a berberine which is helps
improve insulin resistance okay cinnamon
goat's rue green tea bitter melon all of
these improve insulin resistance so it's
something to do research on as a way to
possibly avoid these side effects
alright thanks for watching hey guys I
want to personally invite you to a new
Facebook group that I just started
called dr. Berg's keto and intermittent
fasting lab ok so I created this so we
can share our successful actions what
worked what didn't work the results so I
put a link down below so go ahead and
sign up and I'll see you inside